hey guys justin here at san diego
comic-con hanging out in the xbox gamer
lounge at i'm talking with forest who is
one of the producers at press plays
studios and she has a really awesome
project that she's working on right now
and here in the xbox gamer lounge it's
called Project totem what what is this
game exactly we've been working on so
this is a minimalistic puzzle platformer
from press play located in Copenhagen
Denmark and yeah we've got a co-op and
single player and we're just going for a
sort of very minimal but playful and
challenging game and I guess the best
way to learn about the game to describe
it is is to watch it what's going on on
the screen here right now yeah so so the
basic premise is that so we have a
single player right now on screen the
basic premise is that there are two
totem pieces that you control with one
input so he's using the left stick you
can use a d-pad or the left stick and
you have to use the environment to
basically offset or align the totem
pieces and get through your levels what
was the inspiration behind this game
like it's a very distinctive art style I
don't feel like I've seen something like
this before well this is definitely
something fresh and new for press play
but we do always go for playful so we
were in the completion phase of max the
curse of brotherhood and our composure
and audio engineer was actually needing
a creative outlet and this was a side
project for him he was sort of sitting
around his house one day and thought
wouldn't it be interesting to control to
two characters with one input so he
started working on this in his spare
time and there was a party and there was
some drinking and one of our studio
director Zola had this vague memory the
next day and said hey Oscar I remember
you telling you about this super
interesting game can I see it so then
what happened was the studio directors
all got really excited about this
project we put a team against it for a
month
and prototype tit and and then we took
it to green light and this is a project
we have a full team of about 14 people
working on it now and we're aiming for
end of this year to release on xbox one
so why totems that's a very distinctive
thing to pick up on his as the main
character basically why totem you know I
think that I think that the guy's ass go
and vote actually are two brothers who
are that really behind this project and
leading the project I think they just
thought it would be really fun yeah I
think that they were like you know ask
her as I mentioned as a composer and I
think he was really interested in this
sort of like music and this vibe and
these beats and I think yeah and it just
it made sense you know to have two
pieces and the other premise is that you
as you go through the game you're
collecting totem pieces and you're
building the great totem pole so it
makes sense so as it goes on and on
you're actually adding more pieces that
are going to be controlling correct and
as you finish a level you if you do
better you see the points in the corner
the better you do the more awesome your
totem pieces so you might have
sunglasses or a gold pipe or something
like that so and you also have
occasionally have to change the color of
your totem so like you can switch you
have green at the top but that can be
purple when you need to get past these
kind of obstacles right there correct
correct and you're collecting it looks
like start buttons on the xbox
controller it does actually are they
yeah I never thought about that before
it's true I guess there are also
triangles that they'd fit up with the
upper left hand corner yes so with each
pickup basically it's a point system and
you collect them but each time you die
you lose it so we're playing around with
different ideas like a hardcore mode
where you can't die
and I don't think it needs a story
because i love puzzle platformers just
for themselves but but is there a story
behind why they're exploring these crazy
catacombs yeah so okay so the the
background story is that there is a good
shaman and a bad shaman and the bad
shaman basically destroyed the great
totem pole of the world and it's your
job to resurrect it so that's that's the
story behind rebuilding the great totem
pole and of course you need multiple
pieces to make a big awesome totem and
so you're based out of Copenhagen I'm
sure you're a little bit jet-lagged but
is there anything you're really excited
about seeing here at comic-con outside
of the Xbox lounge oh gosh I actually
saw there are some ID at Xbox games over
there that are very very interesting I
think lovers is super interesting and
I'm lovers in a dangerous space-time
yeah I'm definitely keeping my eyes out
for that well yeah a lot of really
awesome indie stuff here Xbox has been
supporting that in a really cool way and
it's awesome to see these kind of
smaller indie titles getting so much
love if you want to try it yourself you
can come by the xbox gamer lounge and
for even more comic con news stay tuned